- On this episode, I talk about
box of the month club ideas,
Facebook video versus YouTube,
and how I got food poisoning this morning.
(upbeat music)
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
What's up, everybody?
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 81
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Let me just say that the two week hiatus
was something that was really hardcore.
I really missed the show.
VaynerNation, thank you
so much for all the tweets,
and the comments on
Instagram, and the e-mails,
talking about how much
you missed the show.
I want you to know, I
missed you guys so much
that this morning, I had food poisoning.
Uh-huh.
And I rarely ever miss,
I mean, I'm never sick.
Like, just don't miss days
and had to miss the entire morning.
I was knocked out and DeMayo
was texting me all morning
saying, "Don't come in.
"It's one of those ironic days
"where I'm here the whole day.
"They're all pretty lightweight meetings,
"we can push them to the end of the week."
And I said, "No, I've gotta
come in and I've gotta do
"episode 81 of The #AskGaryVee Show,
"because people have been waiting,
"and I couldn't disappoint."
So I apologize for having my energy down
a little bit for episode 81.
But India, let's get in
to the show.
- [Voiceover] Chris asks,
"You've done two long-format web shows,
"in a world where gurus
advise keeping online videos
"short and sweet.
"What gives?"
- Chris, a couple of things.
First and foremost, it's
always very dangerous
to listen to the advice
of online marketing gurus.
I think what gives, is very
simply, something that I think
is the right advice, which
is quality trumps everything.
Right?
And so, I remember in 2007,
being flown out to Mountain View
in Sunnyvale by Yahoo and
Google to try to figure out
what gives with Wine Library TV.
Now remember, this is eight years ago,
trying to figure out why
my show was doing so well,
even though it was long.
And so the real answer was quite simple.
Quality is quality is quality.
If I'm able to put out a 15,
20 minute, 30 minute show,
and I can captivate and hold the audience,
well, then it has a chance of doing well.
If I can't, then it won't.
I mean it's not super complicated.
There are plenty of shit 14-second videos.
There are plenty of waste-of-time,
never-get-off-the-ground,
one minute shows.
You will watch a three-hour
Avatar, because it's good,
you will not watch a 15-second commercial
'cause it's crap.
So the length is not the
variable of the quality.
As a matter of fact,
to break DRock's heart,
neither is the sound, or the
lighting, or the production,
it is the message, it is the
message, it is the message.
I'm telling you, it's the message.
Now, DRock has come into my life
and made everything much better.
So I do respect the
production more than I did
in 2006, '07 and '08.
But the truth is, for the fist pump
that he just put out behind the scenes,
the bottom line is, if he
wasn't dealing with this
kind of quality, all the
production he put out
still, wouldn't, matter.
- [Voiceover] Paul asks,
"Can you provide insight into
"how you nurtured your
public speaking chops,
"besides just hustling on stage?
"How do you prepare for a talk?
"Have you ever been
nervous to speak publicly?"
- Paul, great question.
First of all, ridiculously rad picture.
DRock, show it again.
In love with the drone.
Just completely caught
our attention, great job.
The truth is, I hit the
stage somewhere in 2006,
for the first, first time,
as somebody to listen to,
and it was instantaneous.
It was love at first sight.
I loved the stage, the stage loved me.
And so obviously, I've
got a lot of practice.
Matter of fact, what I'm struggling with
more than anything right now,
is that I'm getting into such a rhythm,
I feel like I'm a stand up comic, right,
that I have my kind of talk.
And I take a lot of pride of
making it eight to 15 minutes
out of an hour different
based on the audience,
but I want it to be 45 minutes different.
But I'm kind of a cadence right now,
so obviously I've gotten better.
My timing has gotten
down, but I've never done
anything like, it's kind
of like this show, right?
Like, one of the things I
love about doing Meerkat
behind the scenes now
is that people can see
how little to no editing there really is.
There is no real prep.
I think my biggest secret
is talk about what you know
you're good at, right?
Like, talk about stuff you know.
I try not to answer questions
about foreign-policy
or currency or you know, I
stay away from Bitcoin or
I don't talk about the
things I don't know, right?
I can spew my opinion and
at the end of the day,
this show and everything
else is my opinion,
but boy, is that grounded
in really strong research
and skill and practitioner DNA.
I feel like my opinion
business matters because
of the execution I did to get there,
whereas my opinion on everything
else, I have my opinions
on a lot of things, but
they're not as grounded
and as much researched.
They're more intuitive, which is fine.
Take them for what they are,
you know what opinions are.
I stick to what I know, and
that helps me just scream.
I'm a good communicator by DNA,
and by staying in my comfort
zone, in my lanes of expertise
and the places where I
actually spend my time
honing my craft, it comes
off very clean because
it's very natural because it is natural.
- [Voiceover] Kelton asks,
"What would be the best way
"to sample healthy energy
drinks out to 1000 people
"by the end of the year?"
- Kelton, I took this question
because I want to give you
a shout out and give you
exposure to my audience,
because I appreciate your hustle.
On the flip side, your question is crap.
Let me explain.
To get 1000 people to try your
energy drink, I don't know,
just go to a crowded place
outside and start pouring.
I would have a thousand
people try my energy drink
literally within eight hours on a Saturday
by going to Central Park.
And maybe you live in some rural area,
so get your ass into a car or a train
and find a crap load of people.
Get a goddamn stand and pour
to a bunch of little cups
and you'll hit your
thousand in eight hours.
Shit question.
- Gary, it's magician and
corporate entertainer,
David Ranalli here.
What's the deal with
Facebook's video push?
Do you think they're going
to become a monetized
video platform?
And what does that mean
for people who are starting
a YouTube show in the
coming weeks like I am?
Thanks.
- David, it means that, first of all,
to answer your question, yes,
it means for people
starting YouTube shows,
they should seriously
start considering starting
Facebook shows.
Now that is people that
actually have money, right?
Because where Facebook
video gets really valuable
is when you start spending
$200 to $500 a day
targeting audiences because
you can target at a level
we've never seen before.
And so you know, look, I
think Facebook is a massive,
it's already a massive
competitor to YouTube.
YouTube should actually be concerned
when you layer the data.
Listen, I keep yelling about this.
The data, the data.
The data that Facebook
sits on top that allows you
to target against creates
an ultimate machine.
And you know, I'm spending a ton of time,
I'm looking at Andy.
No I'm not, I thought that was Andy.
I'm trying to look at
Andy K right now, my team,
who grows audience with me,
and Facebook video is at
the top, the tippy top
of our concern.
And I think now that
they're showing view count
and now that they're
embedded, one of the reasons
I like using YouTube is it
shows perception is reality,
how many views.
It builds brand.
Now that I can do the
same thing with Facebook,
my intentions are to
maybe even switch some...
If you ask me if my primary
embed was Facebook video
over YouTube video six months from today
on Gary Vaynerchuk business
videos, I would say yes.
Think about that.
So it's a huge, huge deal.
It also, I think, competition
breeds innovation.
And so I'm excited because
I think YouTube gets scared
a little bit here.
Google gets scared a little bit here,
and we'll actually see
better quality innovation
come out of YouTube because
they've been pretty stale
for a half decade in a lot of ways.
And I think that they're
going to both push each other.
Now you've got live streaming video.
Video is king, and we're living
some of the picture revolution, right,
Instagram at the forefront.
But I think video still
has a long way to go,
and we're living through
it, and I just think
there's more upside, more
in both categories actually.
But I think Facebook
video is probably grossly
underestimated by the far majority
of this audience right now.
I think the upside is enormous.
I myself am paying a
ton of attention to it.
You know what that speaks.
- [Voiceover] Michelle
asks, "What's your take
"on subscription box services?"
- Michelle, first and
foremost, congratulations.
That is an adorable picture.
It's really cute, and I fully expect you
and that little one to send
me a version of that picture
10 years from today since
I put you on the show,
and I'd like to see it.
So I'm looking forward to being surprised
and trying to recall why it's
happening 10 years from today.
Big shout out to 2025.
The answer to your question,
box services, look,
I wrote one of the first
checks into Birchbox
and was an angel investor in BarkBox.
We're incubating a business
here called Faithbox.
I'm a very big fan of the
subscription box service.
I think it's the way people like to buy.
We like to buy once and forget about it.
I think they're good
businesses because then,
even if we get stuff we
don't want, we don't cancel
right away.
So you get an extra two
to five, seven months
worth of business.
That's just the truth.
And so
I'm very bullish on them,
and I think that there's
innovation to be had.
I think that the box was
kind of the innovation.
All this is, is the month club, right?
It's just the basket of the month club.
So I've been thinking
for a long time like,
what else can I ship it in?
Can it be like a balloon?
Like, can it be like peanutballoon.com,
where like a balloon lands
and there's peanuts in it
each month?
I feel like the mechanism, the box itself
has some innovation around it.
I hope that idea spurred
a thought for somebody
and they start a huge million-dollar
business because of it.
I definitely think that
there's a play there.
As far as upping the hustle, I would say
the birth of a new child is
one of the most remarkable,
important moments of one's life.
And even though I'm 24/7, 365 hustle,
much like I talk about,
getting plenty of sleep
and vacations matter.
It's what you do when you're awake.
I wouldn't overstress the
first one to 10 months,
depending on your DNA.
I would really focus on
laying the foundation
of a healthy relationship
and lifestyle for your baby.
You've got plenty of
time to pick it back up.
Unless you're a maniac like
me, then I would just say,
just a little less sleep and
try to prioritize your health
and vitamins and drink
water and stuff like that.
Don't eat weird food
that makes you throw up
for seven hours the next morning.
And that's it.
Question of the day.
Let's have India ask the question today.
I like the on the spot stuff.
Shift it quickly, don't give her time.
- Oh, I'm so terrible at this.
- [Gary] This is so rewarding.
As a matter of fact, double switcheroo,
Alex gets to ask the question of the day!
(laughs)
Yes.
- How much wood would a woodchuck chuck--
- [Gary] No, we'll not accept that.
Back to India, back to
India, back to India.
- Have you ever had food poisoning?
That's my question.
- Jesus Christ, I'll take over.
Take a picture of your home
screen on your phone right now
and tweet it to me at @GaryVee.
I want to see the apps
that dominate your day.
So you know what, I failed.
Nobody asked the question of the day.
It was the dictation of the day.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Wearing around her neck today, what--
- [India] Scarf.
- [Gary] That is not a scarf.
- Yeah it is, it's a circle scarf.
- [Alex] Yeah, infinity
scarf. Infinity scarf.
- You just wrap it around your head.
It's a circle, it never ends.
I'm cold.
You know I'm always cold.
- I know, I'm always hot.
Tsk.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] (mumbles)
- That is not the beta test Meerkat.
I'm using the actual one
that's in the App Store.
- [Voiceover] All right,
so we should be fine.
- So we should be fine.
But great job by
founder and CEO of Meerkat.
What's up my man?
How many peeps in there?
- [Voiceover] 339.
- Three, three, nine.
Awesome, cool!